la tradición china basándose en el
calendario lunar fijado como el día más
caluroso del año no es equivocado las
temperaturas se han disparado y no
bajarán en la próxima semana es el
verano más caluroso que se recuerda el
calor llegó antes y se marchará más
tarde así que lo que los chinos conocen
como el shampoo es decir esos tres
períodos de 10 días de temperatura y
humedad extremas entre julio a agosto
este año se alargará desde los 30 a los
40 días más de 70 estaciones térmicas
han registrado sus cotas históricas y el
verano está siendo especialmente
inclemente con shanghai alcanzó los 41
grados por primera vez en su historia y
enlazó tres días por encima de los 40
grados cuando en el siglo y medio
anterior sólo había ocurrido en una
quincena de ocasiones de esos días es
célebre la foto de un funcionario con el
traje de protección integral realizando
el test anti cobit y que en un descanso
se abraza a un bloque de hielo de un
metro de alto el calor extremo también
tendrá consecuencias económicas porque
el uso masivo de aparatos de aire
acondicionado
y el consumo energético a sus máximos
varias provincias han recomendado el
ahorro energético a los particulares y
no se descartan cortes de suministro
también es muy probable que merme la
producción de grano y se temen sus
efectos inflacionarios en la carne de
cerdo capital en la dieta china y ha
subido el precio después de que se
encareciera el pienso